vraiment le monument ça va en prendre
beaucoup de fer forgé françois legault
savoure son début de semaine
après des jours difficiles à défendre sa
gestion de la pandémie dans les ch et
celle des
[Applaudissements]
la victoire de cholet doris mandant
marie-victorin lui permet de tourner les
projecteurs vers ses adversaires qui
tente de justifier leur défaite à québec
cela donne des clés de nos succès c'est
le vote des jeunes ce vote là on a eu de
la difficulté à le faire sortir dans
marie-victorin notamment parce que dans
les élections partielles n'y a pas de
vote sur les campus québec solidaire a
vu ses appuis fondre de sept points de
pourcentage par rapport à l'élection
générale de 2018 malgré une visibilité
médiatique plus grande
le parti québécois lui a perdu son
château fort depuis quarante ans après
multiair est un excellent résultat
le chef se défend d'être dans le déni si
la cac n'a pas réussi à faire mieux
malgré sa popularité national c'est à
cause de la rivalité du véhicule selon
lui pour l'élection générale dans mary
vecteur il ya un seul parti qui peut
battre la caq c'est nous je dois faire
le constat avec beaucoup d'humilité de
ce qui s'est passé hier seule la chef
libéral fait un mea culpa dominique
anglade reconnaît ne pas avoir entendu
ses membres qui voulait l'entendre
parler d'économie et de liberté
individuelle elle qui tente un virage
progressiste qui semble peu populaire
auprès de sa base j'ai jamais dit que ce
serait facile non plus d'opérer un tel
virage si un message hier important pour
dominique anglade de 10/20 boulot c'est
de la boulonnerie québécois mme posso
françois legault lui donne des leçons
mais le premier ministre doit tout de
même garder un oeil sur son rétroviseur
le parti conservateur a fait mieux que
les libéraux à longueuil tous les partis
politiques
mérite notre attention
et cette attention se tournera vers la
région de québec éric duhaime réussi a
aussi ses appuis dans une
circonscription qui n'est pas réputée
conservatrice
qu'en sera-t-il de la capitale nationale
à l'élection générale
ici véronique prince radio canada québec